the Senate is returning unusually this
weekend try and cut a deal Peter that's
right a rare Sunday Session for the US
Senate it's an effort by Mitch McConnell
the Senate Majority Leader to force
action but right now Eric there are
back-channel conversations but no deal
on the table the easy solution the White
House says is for the Senate to simply
adopt the house-passed bill the
bipartisan bill that reforms these
programs ends the NSA's collection of
Americans phone debt records and instead
counts on the private sector the phone
companies to hold that material and then
with through court order the
intelligence community could access
those records the problem with that is
that mitch mcconnell himself opposes
that doesn't think it's strong enough he
favors an extension of the current law
and on the other side you've got his
Republican Senate counterpart from
Kentucky Rand Paul who opposes both an
extension and the House bill because he
thinks they go too far gives the
government too much power still that's
why you have this standoff in the former
NSA general counsel store Baker tells me
he thinks these programs will expire on
Sunday I think we're looking at some
perhaps short disappearance of these
authorities because it it's not possible
to agree on legislation that both houses
can pass before the end of the day or
the beginning of the day on the first
Stuart Baker tells me the most likely
scenario here is that the House bill
will have to be tweaked in some way to
satisfy McConnell that's the most likely
roadmap out of here but there's no deal
and if there is no deal Eric and
Stephanie starting at 359 on Sunday the
NSA is going to start pulling the plugs
boy oh boy Peter thank you very much
that is our chief Washington
correspondent Peter Cook it is a
divisive highly debated issue Homeland
Security and just what kinds of power
the government should have you know it's
black and white look at Liberty security
right